what's going on guys this is rob uh if
you guys enjoy my content make sure you
hit the subscribe button
and make sure you hit that little bell
so you never miss out on my sexy voice
okay uh what's going on guys i have no
idea how this is gonna turn out i
haven't sound checked i haven't uh
i don't even look at this in post i have
no clue how this is gonna and
my girlfriend's over here laughing i
have no idea how this is how this is
gonna turn out and i won't know until
post and i'll probably upload it anyway
what the hell
anyway uh essentially how much explains
the teaching channel so why not teach it
like a tree like a classroom or
something like that
um yes there will still be coming panels
because you guys gotta know what the
heck i'm talking about
the topic of today's video what has
captain marvel been doing since
whatever the heck it was she first
showed up in the 1990s
um all right movie's not out yet so we
don't know definitively
but there are a couple ideas floating
around in reality
all right captain let's talk about
captain marvel for a second like who is
carol danvers who's captain marvel
captain marvel was marvel really as
carol danvers originally she was miss
marvel but she was the answer
marvel's answer to wonder woman in 1968.
she was popular until the late 1970s
when her solo series ended
uh and then she was rolled over to the
x-men and then chris claremont said
tara you have the power of a white dwarf
star which made her binary what does
that mean
she can do whatever in the hell she
wants to uh in comic book terms we call
that hashtag comic logic
doesn't have to make sense just has to
work uh and then she free floated for 25
years and became popular in 2012
so that's basically the entire concept
of captain marvel in that show
anyway in the marvel cinematic universe
the question people have is what has she
been doing
okay what captain marvel has likely been
doing markers what captain marvel has
likely
been doing since the start of the since
uh
since she made since her movie probably
ended between the time their movie ended
in the beginning of
avengers 4 is fighting in a conflict
known as the cree
scroll
ward all right
what is the cree scroll war okay imagine
that the united states and britain were
at war with each other
and imagine that atlantis whether it's
fictional or not
is an actual continent that sits in the
middle of the atlantic ocean
atlantis would be the marvel comics
equivalent of earth
with earth itself being the entirety of
the universe right so like
the the home planet of the cree is
called holland the home planet of the
scrolls is called scrollos
at least it was until galactus destroyed
it but that was their home planet and
the idea was that if either race
conquered
earth that they would have a strategic
advantage over the other race so if the
skulls conquered earth they'd have an
advantage over the cree
and vice versa the the basis behind this
goes back god forever it goes back years
and years and years and years probably
like like
millions of years like two to three or
you know millions of years and the
reason why is because somewhere along
the line
the scrolls themselves became an
enlightened monarch and the reason why
was because originally the scrolls were
basically a war-torn race
what this means is that the scrolls as
you'll see them in the marvel cinematic
universe
are actually what are called deviant
scrolls if you don't know what that
means it doesn't matter but basically
they can shape shift it's like the only
real power that they have
the basis behind the enlightened monarch
was that literally the the royal i guess
the rule of the scroll race still
follow alongside royal lineage but they
were more of like explorers and artisans
as opposed to like
warriors right and then like the cree
were still a relatively primitive race
at the time that the scroll of
the squirrels were expanding their
empire and so the scrolls showed up on
the creed planet of hala which was
occupied by two races the cree
and then the kotari so imagine group but
with leaves and so the idea behind this
was the scroll said we want to expand
our race we're going to test the two of
your races
and we're going to drop you guys off on
the blue area of earth's moon what does
that mean
the blue area of the moon on earth is
basically
a portion of the moon uh that has
oxygen whatever comical anyway
they dropped them off they said we're
gonna leave you guys here for a year
we're gonna give you resources and we're
going to come back at the end of the
year and see what you guys
built when the year was up the the crete
race had built like this giant citadel
for themselves
and the kotati had built this lush
jungle and because the squirrels were
a enlightened monarch they said we'd
like to go today more than we like the
creep
and so what it meant was that the cree
were literally like just pissed like
they were really pissed off
they killed the scroll emperor who
showed up they killed the scroll
delegation they reverse engineered the
technology
and then the two races went to war where
they've been fighting for however many
millions of years
and it's been going on like that forever
and ever and ever and ever and ever
so what's likely going on here is that
at the time the captain marvel movie
drops
and at the between the time that the
movie ends and the time that avengers 4
picks up
this has been going on in the background
the entire time that's basically what's
been happening here
now there were a couple other things
that went on in marvel comments with
regards to
like how this the pre-scroll work
impacted things
so what you had is you had the original
marvel right like this this guy's name
was literally
m a r
uh dash b e l
l i'm pretty sure that's how you spell
it it was marvel and he was essentially
just like this
priest soldier right and so the idea was
that the cree sent him to earth to see
whether or not earth could be conquered
and then he basically turned against the
kree empire and joined the avengers what
this
did is it led to the arrival of of jude
law's character
in the marvel cinematic universe captain
marvel movie a guy by the name of
yon i think that's how you spell it
wrong john rock was basically a general
for the kree empire
but he ended up harboring a personal
vendetta against marvel
due to the extreme patriotism for lack
of a better word of yanuk
and the fact that marvel committed
treason there were a couple of things
going on behind the scenes doesn't
really matter
anyway the crease world war became
exceedingly close to earth
and almost led to like a full-scale
invasion of earth
by the cree i think it was and there's
alternate reality stories of marvel
comics like what if stories were like
the cree actually invaded her in fact
during the original age of ultron story
by bendis
there's a future where that actually
happened and earth was just like
derelict
it was absolutely bonkers of war torn
and all kinds of great stuff
anyway because of how close the
pre-scroll war
came to earth what you ended up having
is you had a handful of guys
you had professor xavier
professor x of the x-men you had black
bolt
which i hope you guys can see this black
hole of the inhumans
he doesn't really matter because black
bolt sucks um you had
black panther
and then you had uh reed richards mr
fantastic for those of you guys who are
not familiar with comics
uh reed richards
you had doctor strange
and then you had iron and then it wasn't
until hickman's avengers and new
avengers that we found out that captain
america was actually part of it which
was kind of weird
but the idea behind this is that these
guys essentially
formed a group
they formed a group that was called
the illuminati
they formed a group called the
illuminati and the idea behind the
illuminati is that they were basically
going to safeguard earth from threats
uh by pulling all their information
together because professor x had various
bits of information about the pre-school
war
so did black bolts sort of black
panthers sort of read richards doctor
strange and iron man
but none of them really worked together
and that's why the previous world war
came as close to earth as it did
and so the idea was that if they had
pulled all their information together
the conflict would have would never have
come as close to earth as it did
and earth never would have been in
jeopardy of being conquered and or
destroyed
and so forming the illuminati they said
they're going to safeguard everything
the first thing the illuminati did
was they banished the incredible hall
and they said we're going to send you to
a different planet where you're
basically going to live in peace
and ultimately the incredible hulk flew
through a gravity well which landed him
on zakar and that's where planet hulk
picks up which leads to world war hulk
and all that kind of cool stuff
but what this means is that for the
future of the marvel cinematic universe
a lot of things can come out of the
aftermath of the pre-school war
i wouldn't expect him to come out like
that right like wouldn't expect a
post-credits scene at the end of
avengers 4
with like all these guys forming the
illuminati but what it does mean
is that there are a litany of
circumstances that can be developed as a
result of this whole
entire conflict because in reality in
marvel comics it was a landmark event it
was one of the biggest events
and one of the like really the first
major crossover of its kind
that marvel had had uh had developed it
was actually written by a guy
written by a guy who was oh it was
written by uh
roy thomas
that's not really important but just a
little bit of information anyway um
kind of like rest here you know towards
the end but that's the basis behind this
is that most likely carol danvers has
been fighting alongside the creed
against the scrolls and the crease world
war and has been doing that the entire
time
what state the crease rewards in we
don't know and if anything
if it's anything like marvel comics then
from there it'll just turn into what'll
likely be like an expansion
of the entirety of the marvel cinematic
universe so what you're to start seeing
they start focusing on
the universe as a whole they leave earth
and they start focusing on the universe
well then you get this in lobbyists
which is the race that silver surfer
belongs to you you get the shiar
empire which you probably won't see the
shia empire has a weird name
uh it's weird the way it's spelled it's
basically s
h i apostrophe a
r but the she arg empire is the race
that basically coincides alongside like
the phoenix force
um which means you can start diving into
things like that there's a linear places
they can go from here
all based off of the crease for a war
and using that as a means to catapult
into like
the bigger universe in a much larger way
i don't know if that makes any sense
hopefully it does
uh let me know what you guys think about
the this format i mean again this is
kind of like a one-off
no idea if it'll work i'm kind of
curious myself if i'm being honest
uh but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rav4 if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you